hey guys I don't normally do standalone
book reviews but this book has been
probably the most requested thing for me
to read both on here and on my Goodreads
and I just tore through it and I've got
some thoughts I got some thoughts on
this before I say anything else I've got
to say huge thank you to my friend David
who gave me this as a birthday present
you were right David I did really enjoy
it so thank you very much for that
please now maybe turn off the review so
don't hear all the nasty things I'm
going to say about this book because as
you will have seen in the title I
decided to give this 3 out of 5 stars
this is another reason why I thought I
should do a standalone video about it
because all the people who recommend it
to me loads of people have loved this
book and I think I've come to something
of a different conclusion and I want to
make a video talking about why I've done
that is three stars a bit of a harsh
rating yes I think so am i doing it
needlessly to try and caught popularity
on YouTube however do I think this
rating is reflective of my perceptions
towards the book yes I think this is a
fair rating and allow me to explain why
for those of you who haven't read the
book the name of the wind by Patrick
Rothfuss is the first in the King Killer
chronicles I think it's called yes the
king king of koala calls day one
day one is actually that's a very cool
part of the book because it takes place
in a what I would call a medium fantasy
setting a bit like latter day game with
Thrones in that magic exists but it's
rare people don't seem to know very much
about it there are things like dragons
in the world but it's not high fantasy
and in this setting we're introduced to
a character called cook I've never
actually said that out loud before give
off give off give off when juice to a
character called Cove off who has a
monologue on the back page and is
represented first of all as an innkeeper
and then it turns out he's got very
interesting backstory and he over the
course of three days tells his story to
a travelling chronicler who writes his
story down this book is what he says on
the first day as a structure I really
like that because you get more than just
the story in the introduction you're
introduced to this character and we're
intrigued about his backstory as he
tells the story sometimes there are
interludes we get people asking
questions about what's just happened in
the story and then the
and it provides a nice framing this is a
non-spoiler review just saying it also
introduces a few issues which I'm going
to come back to to very briefly
summarize what he says in the first day
it's about his childhood he then
undergoes a period of loss he then goes
on an adventure and eventually ends up
at a university and a bunch of things
happen along the way that's very
condensed and there's a bunch of stuff
that I really like in the book in
particular I really like the way that
magic is done magic is almost like
science almost like physics in that
there are rules of magic which is
referred to as sympathy it's presented
in a very rational way rather than just
like there are winds of magic like some
voluminous ether like some Victorian
science this is this feels very grounded
and I really really like that the book
is also written very cinematically there
are some really like powerful images
that kind of at least struck me square
between the eyes I was like I know
exactly what that looks like it's like a
still from a film that's playing out and
I think that it was written with that in
mind with with quite a cinematic
vocabulary and as a side note in that
vein the university in the book very
much reminds me of Oxford which I really
isn't probably a terribly common like
comparison because you know not many
people get like ie reminded me of going
to uni but at the end of the day I think
the biggest positive I drew from this
book was that it was very very
entertaining i demolished it it's like
it's 650 odd pages and I read it in I
think less than a week by I just
devoured this book because it was a
really really fun read I really enjoyed
myself which at the end of the day is
what could off in the inners of trying
to accomplish she's spinning a tale that
you're going to enjoy listening to in
this case reading any kind of harkens
back to the roots of storytelling you're
listening to one narrator telling his or
her story and you know the setting lends
itself to that the fact that it's this
fantasy setting you're sat on a pub you
can imagine a fire crackling and you're
listening to this person's story that it
does that really really well I really
enjoyed reading the book however I do
have some problems with the book getting
increasing order of magnitude it's not
it's fault it's a fault of the genre I
just didn't like some of the language
that it used in writing it's very florid
kind of style which is quite specific to
fantasy and the more
go towards high fantasy the more you get
like this I just didn't particularly
enjoy that the villain is almost kind of
comically stereotyped you were
introduced to the big bad of the whole
story but they are yeah like I say kind
of comically stereotyped their faces
reads didn't shadow and there's all
these things that you have seen and all
their tropes basically it's a dare I say
quite an unimaginative main villain at
this point I'm sure they probably get
more interesting in other books but
based on this one book not terribly
interested and I refer to them as the
big bag despite the fact that there is
no real kind of bad guy in this book
there's one student that curved off
really spars with at university we'll
get onto that again in just a second but
there is a lack of traditional if you
like story structure to the book I found
the structure of it quite underwhelming
it just seems to be one thing after
another without any kind of overarching
point to it yes I know this is episode
one if you like of a trilogy but it just
felt a little bit like oh there you go
then this happened then this happened
then this happened I felt like it lacked
that kind of storytelling structure
which is kind of ironic considering that
like I said earlier it harkens back to
the roots of storytelling and you know
in its most basic form it's just one guy
telling you a story
yes yeah it didn't hang together however
my biggest criticism of the book is
Thoth let me read you actually something
I have stolen princesses back from
Sleeping Bear Kings I burned down the
town of TREB on I have spent the night
with valerian and left with both my
sanity and my life I was expelled from
the University at a younger age than
most people are allowed in I tread paths
by moon lights that others fear to speak
of during day I have talked to God's
loved women and written songs that make
the minstrels weep my name is Kevon you
may have heard of me now there are two
options of how to interpret that because
with give off telling his own story and
he's the only person there who's telling
the story we have the problem of an
unreliable narrator meaning that things
may not have happened the way that he
says they did and there's nobody to
question him so he'll be free to
embellish a few things change a few
details and make himself look much
better or on the other hand that
description that monologue from the back
may be actually accurate and all the
things happened either one of those I
had a problem with because during the
story curve off has no flaws and that is
my main problem with this book is that
our protagonist is flawless not flawless
in the sense that he's a perfect
protagonist very well written I'm saying
that he doesn't have any flaws as a
character regardless of the situation
Kavitha somehow is the best at whatever
he does whether that be music or magic
or respecting women or you know he has
all these women falling over him he
makes people weep with his music he goes
to university and finds it easy he
embarrasses the lecturer that nobody
likes there is nothing he does that
indicates any kind of flaw in him
whatsoever
the only thing approaching a flaw is
that he doesn't know how to talk to
women because he's young that isn't a
flaw however because they are literally
falling at him and it's presented as
that I was just so virtuous I didn't
know what I was doing I couldn't do
anything you know there was one passage
in particular where the bad guy of this
book the student here Esparza as I said
earlier talking to a female student that
bartha's previously talked to and liked
and basically just walks in and in
effect dismisses the guy with his wit
and his charm and just runs circles
around him and you know it's like well
I've got to go in there and respect this
woman and I pretty much out loud I think
when I'll cough cough because it just
wreaked of well I'm naturally I went in
and I did this and I saved the day which
leaves us with our two possibilities one
this didn't actually happen and
kavitha's embellishing the story to make
us like him or on the other hand this is
what actually happened and he's a
completely flawless person either of
these situations involved him being a
massive prick we're confronted with
either having a narrator who is lying to
us as the reader and not even in an
endearing way he's just a smarmy git
who's making us trying to make us like
him more by saying you know he did all
of these things and you know yes I
naturally had to go and defend her honor
oh he's just a badly written character
with nothing wrong with him and it just
got tiring reading him being the best
and being perfect at everything over and
over and over again
no one is like that if you want to make
a protagonist that is likable and that
we want to get behind and want to see
succeed got to give them something that
they're fighting against other than the
circumstance but
yes things go terribly wrong and cut off
his life he's dealing with these
obstacles but they are not on his design
he has to make mistakes and then in some
way overcome them
yes there is a mistake involving the
archives which people have read the book
will know about and spoil it but that
wasn't a result of a flaw in lost
character he was just tired when that
instant happened and it's basically the
villains fault to me I just didn't like
both and yeah I want to read the next
book because I enjoyed reading this but
I'm going into it kind of jaded with him
as a character like I said at the start
perhaps this is being a little bit harsh
but in reading this book perhaps because
I was hyped up by so many people that
was gonna really really enjoy it I just
I just didn't like him and I really
enjoyed the book and I wanted to enjoy
the book so you know thumbs up but I was
left disappointed with the writing of
our protagonist and considering it stole
from a first-person perspective that's
quite a major flaw in the book I think
this is quite different from a lot of
other people's interpretations of this
book I would really like to hear your
interpretation if you've read this do
you agree with any of the points I've
made do you think I am completely wrong
I am going to be reading the comments on
this one like a hawk so please put your
opinion down there below thank you again
David for buying me this book I did
enjoy it I'm gonna be reading the sequel
very soon and of course thank you for
watching and making it to the end of the
video if you like you can check out my
Goodreads there's a link in the
description and there'll also be a link
to all the book videos I've done because
I like talking about books on this
channel thanks for watching I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
you
[Music]